Hi, welcome back to this my final
session on value investing. But let's
see where we are in this process. After
I introduce value investing by talking
about Ben Graham and Warren Buffett, we
looked at screening, you know, looking
for low PE, low price to book, high
dividend yield stocks and how that has
performed over time in terms of
delivering excess returns. We turned to
contrarian value investing where you buy
stocks after a price drop but where the
fundamentals have suggest the value is
still holding up. We talked about
activist value investing where you come
into a company that you think is not not
just undervalued but poorly managed and
change the way it's run. In this my
final session I want to talk about
looking at value investing in the
aggregate both in its glory days of the
20th century and in the 21st century
where it struggled. look at whether in
fact it was as glorious as it was made
out to be during the glory days and why
it's struggling now. So let's set the
table. Let's start by looking at by
decade the returns to PE and price to
book traditional screens for tra for
value investing. In each of the decades
I've looked at the lowest price to book
stocks and the highest price price to
book stocks the annual returns and put
the difference. And as you can see in
the last three decades in two of the
three 1990 through99 and 2010 to 2019
value investing at least in its
traditional form low PE low price to
book has underperformed
high price earnings and high price to
book. We'll file that away. You could
argue that it's just a temporary phase
but that's a long period 30 years where
value investing has struggled.
But if you were to look across time,
it's true value investing looks like it
delivered higher returns than growth
investing at least with very generic
screens.
So I want to take a closer look at the
20th century at those glory days so to
speak where low price to earnings and
low price to book stocks did better than
price high price earnings and high price
to book stocks. And I'm going to make
two arguments. Even in those glory days,
there were periods where value investing
underperformed. And even in those glory
days, active value investing, we
actually went out and did research and
found undervalued companies didn't
actually deliver much value. Of course,
in recent years, all of these screens
have kind of fallen off. I want to look
at why that might have happened and what
value investing might need to do to kind
of rediscover itself. It's a lot on the
plate. So, let's start by looking at
value investing versus growth investing
by year. In the previous tables and
graphs, we looked at value investing in
the aggregate. Here, I've looked at the
lowest versus highest decile of price to
book stocks by year going back to 1927.
And you look across time, you can see
there are good years and bad years. And
in the 93 years of data that I have in
this graph in
93 years low price to book wins but in
44 the high price to book stocks
portfolio wins. So even though in the on
average in the aggregate low price to
book stocks earned higher returns than
high price to book stocks it's almost
50/50 in terms of a year-to-year basis.
If you have a one-year time horizon and
you thought value investing was going to
deliver you excess returns and you
bought low price to book stocks, half
the time you'd have been disappointed.
If you dig a little deeper and look at
active value investing where you
actually go out and do research and look
at the management and assess the value
of the company, there's remarkably
little evidence that that has actually
created value in terms of higher
returns. And the question is, if value
investing is just coming from buying low
price earnings and low price to book
stocks, in what sense is it value
investing? Because there's nothing
you're doing as a value investor that's
adding to the game. There are two pieces
of research that I'm going to use to
back up the proposition that active
value investing where you go out and do
research hasn't historically paid off.
The first is by looking at institutional
investors who classify themselves as
value funds or growth funds.
Instead of comparing these funds to the
S&P 500 where the value funds will start
with an advantage simply because of the
history of low price to book stocks,
I've compared value funds to an index
fund of value stocks. You just buy low
price to book stocks and a growth fund
with an index fund of growth stocks.
High price earnings, high price to book
stocks. Effectively what I'm saying or
looking for is what is the value added
by looking at investing in an active
value fund. A fund that goes out and
says we're going to look for cheap
companies as opposed to just buying a
value index fund. And the evidence and
this is where it's one slice of history.
It could be different in different
slices suggests that in terms of value
added
value funds actually add less value than
growth funds. In other words, activeness
in value funds actually makes your
returns worse than just buying a value
index fund. With growth funds,
activeness adds value. There's something
that growth investors do that can add
value. That's not great news if you're a
value investor because it suggests that
research has a bigger payoff in growth
stocks and in value stocks. One slice of
history. You're saying what about
individuals? Maybe institutions are not
that good at value investing. Here the
evidence is a little better.
On average, active individual value
investors still underperform by about
1%.
And it's heavily skewed. The very top
quintile outperforms the market by about
6%. So there's an element of hope here,
right? If you're an individual investor,
you believe in value, you do research,
and in the top quartile, you outperform
the market by about 6%. And if you look
a little deeper at these winners, there
tends to be more home buyers. you stay
close to the things you know and the
portfolios are concentrated
and the more you trade the lower your
returns become. So individuals do a
little better than institutions in terms
of creating value from research.
But
on average they too underperform the
market. But if you're a really good
individual investor, maybe there's hope
and that was in the good days. They're
saying what about activists value
investors? On average they've they've
added value and you saw that with the
excess returns over time. But on
average, if you look across time, those
returns have drifted down as private
equity has become bigger. It's attracted
more capital, more average investors.
The returns are very volatile on a
year-to-year basis, and they're very
skewed. The biggest winners account for
much of the excess returns. So, if you
were to look at the evidence in active
activist value investing, if you were
invested in the very best activist value
funds, you were beating the market.
keyword is were but you might no longer
be as the business has matured and drawn
in more capital. So even in its glory
days on a year-to-year basis the value
outperformance was volatile. active
value investing did not add much value
either at the institutional level or the
individual level. And the bottom line is
we're entering into a new century where
even the traditional value investing
ways of making excess returns. The old
screens
don't seem to be working. As you saw,
low price earning stocks, low price to
book stocks, at least in the last 10
years, the last 15 years have
underperformed the market. And value
investors are facing an existential
question. Have things changed so much
that you need to move on, find different
ways of investing or is this too
something that shall pass? There are
many value investors who hold on to hope
that this is a passing phase that they
can go back to buying low PE stocks and
low price to book stocks and earn
returns. Some blame central banks for
their problems. Others argue it's index
funds that have caused the problems.
They're looking for excuses essentially
that tell them this too shall pass. But
at least some value investors are
starting to re-examine what they do. Say
maybe there's something about the
traditional way of thinking about value
investing that is no longer working. And
I have something to add to that
discussion. You might not like what I
have to say, especially if you're an
old-time value investor, but I have to
speak my heart. I think value investing
has lost its way. It's lost its way
because it's become rigid. Things you
can do and things you're not supposed to
do through
classifying investors as shallow or as
good investors. It's become rigid. It's
very ritualistic. There are things
you're supposed to do as a value
investor. Pay heed to this Shilipe. Talk
about Warren Buffett. View everything he
says as effectively the truth. It's
rigid. It's ritualistic. And it's very
rightish. righteous in what sense?
Old-time value investors think seem to
think that they're entitled to a reward.
Why? Because they've done the right
things. They've gone to the right
places. They've done the right research.
And when you're righteous and you don't
get your returns, you start to get
frustrated and angry and you take it out
in the market. Value investing has
become rigid. It's become ritualistic.
It's become righteous. And in the
process, it's become a place where it's
very difficult to create change.
I think of myself as a value investor
but not in the traditional sense. Here
are some things I think we need to open
the door to as value investors to do it
better. First, if you're a value
investor, let's talk about value. Much
of value investing as practiced today is
a screening low PE, low price to book.
And what sense is that value? You're not
valuing companies. You're not the growth
and the risk. In fact, I am surprised at
how many push back I how much push back
I get from value investors when I talk
about intrinsic valuation. Those are
estimates. It's speculation.
If you are unwilling to actually value
companies, I don't see how you can use
the word value investor to describe what
you do. You can't view discounted cash
flow valuation as an academic exercise.
You have to get your hands dirty and
actually value companies. And you have
to be clear about the difference between
value and price. Price is driven by
demand and supply. Value by cash flows,
growth and risk. And what the difference
is second, you can't stay in the Ben
Graham mode of avoiding uncertainty. I
can understand why Ben Graham did it. He
came out of the Great Depression and to
him this was the key to avoid taking
risk. But if you avoid taking risk, it
has consequences.
You're going to end up in terms of the
life cycle with mature and declining
companies in your business. You will
never buy great young growth companies
even if they're undervalued.
If you truly are a value investor, why
wouldn't you find undervalued stocks
which are young growth companies if you
can value them right? Avoiding
uncertainty can't become the endgame and
you can't avoid it. Third, a lot of
value investors talk about the margin of
safety as their alternative to
traditional risk and return models. I've
heard value investors say, "I don't like
betas. I don't like portfolio theory. I
like the margin of safety." I think
you're missing the point. Think of what
the margin of safety is. You first value
an asset and then put in a margin of
safety, 20 or 25%. You buy a stock only
if the price is x% lower than the value.
I can understand why you do it cuz you
could be wrong about your value and
markets might not correct. But to use
the margin of safety, you first need to
value an asset. And to value an asset,
you still need a measure of risk.
Whether it's beta, arbitrage, pricing
model, or some other proxy. Margin of
safety is an add-on. It's a it's not a
substitute for risk and return models
because you need those to value an
asset. And when you you when you do pick
a margin of safety, using a higher
margin of safety is not necessarily a
good thing because there's a trade-off.
And here's a trade-off.
It goes back to something we talk about
in statistics. Type one versus type two
errors. If you set your margin of safety
higher,
you've avoided one type of mistake,
right? You're avoiding those overvalued
stocks that you might buy because you
made a mistake. But you create a second
type of error which is you might not be
buying some undervalued stocks because
you set the margin of safety too high.
So if you set your margin of safety at
50%, it's true you will not be buying an
overvalued stock by mistake. But it's
also true you might not be buying a lot
of undervalued stocks because you set
the margin of safety too high. You think
how would I know if my margin of safety
is too high? There's a very simple
metric to use. Look at your portfolio.
If half your portfolio is in cash, your
margin of safety is way too high. You
need to bring it down because you're not
finding enough to invest in. So margin
of safety is a measure you can use, but
it's a luxury measure, a measure that
works when you have hundreds of
opportunities in the market and you can
take only a subset of those
opportunities.
Fourth piece of advice, don't take
accounting at face value. I've said some
mean things about about accountants and
I won't take them back. Accountants are
not always consistent in the way they
estimate things. So traditional value
investing is so wedded to balance sheet
and income statement numbers that when
accountants grow up, they take along
value investors for the ride. There's a
reason I'm not a great believer in book
value of equity or book value capital
because those are accounting numbers.
And as companies have become more
aggressive in their accounting games,
those accounting numbers become even
less reliable. And as we move away from
manufacturing companies, we've talked
about the accounting inconsistencies
that drive book value and earnings at
technology companies.
I know that many traditional value
investors view concentration is the
right thing to do that you need to hold
a small portfolio because it shows
conviction. I get it. I get it. If you
truly believe that a stock is
undervalued and you're going to make
money on it, you're saying, "Why would I
own 15 stocks when I own when I can own
the best or the three best or the five
best?" I think the choice is a false one
though because it misses the effect of
uncertainty. Uncertainty about your
value, uncertainty about markets
correcting to because even if you're
right about the value that you've
estimated, markets have to adjust to
that value for you to make money. The
more uncertain you feel about your
valuation and about the market
correction, the bigger your portfolio
has to get. And the choice between do
you want to be concentrated
and make excess returns, pick the best
stocks or diversified and be like the
market is a false one because there are
46,000 publicly traded stocks at the
start of 2025.
I can own 25 of them
and still pick good companies. And in
fact, one of the ways to think about how
much diversification is good for you,
I'll turn it back to you. I'm not going
to make the argument that you should
have a more concentrated portfolio. But
if you feel absolutely certain about
your estimate of value and absolutely
certain that the price will adjust to
value, then you should be put all your
money in one stock. The less certain you
feel about both of those, the more
diversified you should get. Finally,
take away the righteousness. Nobody's
entitled to a reward just because
they're value investors.
Invest, invest well, do your homework.
And if you get excess return, treat them
as icing on the cake. And if you don't,
it is how markets behave. you you don't
own the high ground when it comes to an
investment philosophy. You can be a
value investor. Have respect for growth
investors and traders. You know, because
they come to the market with a different
philosophy doesn't mean they're wrong.
Keep an open mind because you might want
to borrow some of the things they do and
make yourself a better investor.
So, I do think that value investors, you
know, have made this defense of, hey,
this is the best way to invest. And I
think we need to step away from the best
way. This is the way that works for you.
And the fact is that you have a long
history backing you and you have some
great investors whose names you can
point to. The very fact that you keep
talking about Warren Buffett tells you
there aren't that many names even in
value investing you point to. But I
think ultimately when you look at does
value investing work, you can't just
point to these names of success. You got
to look at in the aggregate has value
invested add value and the evidence
there is pretty weak on all of that work
going into value investing actually
showing up as excess returns.
So in conclusion value investing comes
in lots of different forms. There are
these screeners who follow the Ben
Graham approach and screen for cheap
companies that are contrarian value
investors who look for stocks that have
dropped but who the value still is held
up. There are activist investors who try
to change the way a company's run and
each approach seems to have the academic
background saying this works. But in
practice, there's actually surprisingly
little evidence that any of these
approaches create value. It's hard work
and why would it not be? Investing is
one of the toughest businesses to win
at. And the fact that you're value
investor doesn't take away from the
toughness. I hope you found the session
useful and I thank you very much for
listening.